o vinagre de maçã orgânico substitui
enzimas digestivas não não substitui o
vinagre de maçã orgânico ele pode ajudar
na saúde do estômago mas ele não vai
substituir enzimas ele vai ter efeitos
benéficos mas as enzimas digestivas vão
ter um efeito muito mais direto na
questão da digestão dos alimentos elas
são naturalmente produzidas pelo corpo e
ajudam a quebrar os alimentos em
nutrientes que podem ser absorvidos
então se você tem uma deficiência de
enzima geralmente Você vai precisar
utilizar sim suplementos com essas
enzimas e sim o vinagre de maçã vai
ajudar mas ele não vai substituir Por
que que o vinag de maçã ajuda a melhorar
a digestão porque contém ácido acético
que vai estimular a produção de suco
gástrico o ácido clorídrico e também vai
ajudar a estimular a produção de enzimas
digestivas naturais no estômago e do
heno Além disso o vinagre de maçã ele
pode ter propriedades antibacterianas
antiinflamatórias que vão ajudar a
manter o equilíbrio da flora da no
microbioma intestinal então é importante
você diluir esse vinagre de maçã em Água
né e tomar com canudinho para não
danificar a dentina né o esmalte dos
dentes o consumo concentrado de vinagre
de maçã pode ser irritante pro estômago
e pros dentes então tem que tomar
cuidado então a dose típica que a gente
recomenda de uma a duas colheres de sopa
de vinagre de maçã diluídas num copo
d'água pequeno e consumido logo Antes
das refeições de você tomar com
canudinho e sempre procure um médico e
nutricionista para fazer o seu
acompanhamento para que você possa ter
um tratamento personalizado ok